.
>> Will: FTX, MORE IN A
MOMENT.
EARLIER IN THE SHOW I MENTION
PAUL PELOSI.
TONIGHT THERE'S MORE CONFUSION
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED INSIDE
NANCY PELOSI'S HOUSE ON
OCTOBER 28.
IF YOU REMEMBER THAT'S WHEN A
NUDIST NAMED DAVID DEPAPE
ATTACKED PAUL PELOSI WITH A
HAMMER.
ACCORDING TO AN INDICTMENT,
POLICE OFFICERS OPENED THE DOOR
TO NANCY PELOSI'S HOME.
THIS IS FASCINATING BECAUSE IT'S
IN DIRECT CONTRADICTION TO THE
FILINGS BY SAN FRANCISCO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO SAY THAT NO,
IN FACT PAUL PELOSI OPENED THE
DOOR.
AN NBC NEWS AFFILIATE IN THE
BAY AREA JUST REPORTED THAT
ACCORDING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
SOURCES WHO SAW BODY CAM
FOOTAGE, THE D.A. IS RIGHT.
THE DOJ IS WRONG.
PAUL PELOSI OPENED THE DOOR.
WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT?
ASKING FOR DETAILS OR FACTS ON
THE COMES OF THIS STORY HAVE
BEEN DISMISSED AS IS A
CONSPIRACY, AS AN ENTIRE
NARRATIVE THAT DAVID DEPAPE WAS
INSURRECTIONIST AND A MAGA
REPUBLICAN WAS BUILT.
NO QUESTIONS THAT COULD GET IN
THE WAY THAT NARRATIVE.
FOR EXAMPLE, THIS ISN'T THE
FIRST TIME THAT NBC NEWS
CONTRADICTED THE DOJ'S
NARRATIVE.
EARLIER THIS MONTH NBC RAN THIS
REPORT WHICH STATED THAT PAUL
PELOSI DIDN'T THINK HE WAS IN
DANGER WHEN DAVID DEPAPE WAS IN
HIS HOME.
>> SOURCES FAMILIAR WITH WHAT
UNFOLDED IN THE PELOSI RESIDENCE
AND REVEALING WHAT OFFICERS
RESPONDED TO THE HIGH-PRIORITY
CALL, THEY WERE SEEMINGLY
UNAWARE THEY'VE BEEN CALLED TO
THE HOME OF THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE.
AFTER A KNOCK, THE FRONT DOOR
WAS OPENED BY MR. PELOSI.
THE 82-YEAR-OLD DID NOT
IMMEDIATELY DECLARE AN EMERGENCY
OR TRY TO LEAVE HIS HOME BUT
INSTEAD BEGAN WALKING SEVERAL
FEET BACK INTO THE FOYER TOWARD
THE ASSAILANT AND AWAY FROM
POLICE.
WHY PELOSI DIDN'T TRY TO FLEE OR
TELL RESPONDING OFFICERS HE WAS
IN DISTRESS IS UNCLEAR.
>> WE STILL DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT UNFOLDED BETWEEN MR. PELOSI
AND THE SUSPECT FOR THE
30 MINUTES THEY WERE ALONE
INSIDE THE HOUSE BEFORE POLICE
ARRIVED.
>> Will: THAT REPORT BY
NBC NEWS, THAT SEEMS TO AT LEAST
BE IN PART SUPPORTED BY THE NEW
INVESTIGATIVE REPORT FROM AN NBC
AFFILIATE IN THE BAY AREA WAS
TOTALLY SCRUBBED FROM HIS
WEBSITE.
THEY ALSO SUSPENDED THAT
REPORTER, MIGUEL ALMAGUER.
HE HAS NOT BEEN HEARD FROM.
NO TWEETS, NO APPEARANCES ON
TELEVISION, FOR ALMOST TWO
WEEKS.
NBC CLAIMS THAT MIGUEL ALMAGUER
VIOLATED THEIR STANDARDS.
WHAT STANDARDS WERE THOSE?
NO NBC REPORTERS WERE EVER
SUSPENDED FOR THE LIES THAT THEY
TOLD IN HELPING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WATCH.
>> RIGHT-WING MEDIA HAS BEEN
FOCUSED ON HUNTER BIDEN, THE
LAPTOP, THAT INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS HAVE WARNED IS LIKELY
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
>> THE STORY IS PREPOSTEROUS.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE THAT
HUNTER BIDEN IN A DRUNKEN STUPOR
DROPPED OFF HIS LAPTOP I GUESS
APPARENTLY QANON REPAIR OFFICES.
IT IS SO OBVIOUS A RUSSIAN
OPERATION.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE.
IT WALKS LIKE RUSSIAN
TALKS LIKE RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE.
THIS EFFORT BY RUDY GIULIANI OF
"THE NEW YORK POST" AND
STEVE BANNON TO COOK UP SUPPOSED
TO DIRT ON JOE BIDEN LOOKS LIKE
A CLASSIC RUSSIAN PLAYBOOK
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN.
>> Will: ALL OF THOSE LIES,
ALL OF THAT MISINFORMATION WAS
APPARENTLY UP TO NBC STANDARDS.
THIS REPORT THAT WE NOW KNOW, OR
SUGGEST IS TRUE, BELOW NBC
STANDARDS.
BUCK SEXTON, HOST OF THE CLAY
TRAVIS AND BUCK SEXTON SHOW.
ALSO A FORMER CIA OFFICER.
LET ME MAKE SENSE OF THIS.
>> I THINK IT'S PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD.
THIS IS YET AGAIN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BEING SHOWN WHAT THE
RULES OF SO-CALLED JOURNALISM.
LIARS GET PULITZERS AND TRUTH
TELLERS GET FIRED OR IN THIS
CASE SUSPENDED, BECAUSE IT'S ALL
ABOUT ACTIVISM.
IT'S ALL ABOUT SUPPORT OF THE
PARTISAN NARRATIVE IN THE
MOMENT.
AS A FORMER INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER, WATCHING THOSE CLIPS OF
PEOPLE SAYING THAT THE HUNTER
BIDEN LAPTOP WAS RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION, THERE'S NOT MUCH
LEFT IN THE INTEL COMMUNITY
THESE DAYS IN TERMS OF
REPUTATION TO PROTECT THEY WERE
CERTAINLY TRYING TO DESTROY AND
THEY DID A GOOD JOB OF IT.
WE SEE THIS TIME AND TIME AGAIN
WHERE EVEN IF EVENTUALLY THE
TRUTH COMES OUT, THERE'S NO
PUNISHMENT.
WE DIDN'T EVEN GET INTO RUSSIA
COLLUSION FOR EXAMPLE WHERE THE
ENTIRE DEMOCRAT ALIGNED
CORPORATE MEDIA SPENT FOUR
YEARS, THEY STILL SAY IT'S KIND
OF TRUE IN SOME WAYS.
YOU ASKED THEM HOW THEY DON'T
REALLY EVER EXPLAIN IT.
BUT THEY UNDERSTAND THESE ARE
ACTUALLY THE RULES.
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE DEALING
WITH.
THIS IS NOT A BUG.
THIS IS A FEATURE.
THIS IS THE DESIRE OF THE
DEMOCRATS TO USE THE BIGGEST
MEDIA OUTLETS THEY POSSIBLY CAN
TO TELL THE MOST IMPORTANT LIES,
THE BIGGEST LIES, OR EVEN JUST
SUPPRESS THE TRUTH IN MOMENTS OF
PERIL FOR THEIR POWER.
WE SAW IT WITH THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP AND WITH THE NANCY PELOSI
STORY, I WOULD POINT OUT, THE
PAUL PELOSI STORY.
THE SECURITY SITUATION ALONE IS
WORTHY OF A SERIOUS
INVESTIGATION.
HOW WAS THIS GUY ABLE TO ATTACK
NANCY PELOSI'S HUSBAND?
THE POLICE RESPONSE.
THIS SHOULD BE SOMETHING
JOURNALISTS WANT TO KNOW RIGHT
AWAY BUT THEY ARE TRYING TO SLOW
WALK IT BECAUSE THEY KNOW THERE
WAS A STORY TO TELL OF THE TIME
TO HELP DEMOCRATS IN THE
ELECTION AND THAT'S ALL THAT
MATTERED.
>> Will: THERE WAS A STORY TO
TELL.
ARE YOU REFERENCING THE ENTIRE
NARRATIVE, THIS ORNATE NARRATIVE
BUILT UPON A FOUNDATION AND
DAVID DEPAPE WAS A MAGA
REPUBLICAN SO THEREFORE THIS IS
CONNECTED TO JANUARY 6.
THAT WAS THE NARRATIVE FILLED
WITH VERY FEW FACTS TO SUPPORT
IT ON ANYTHING THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT IF YOU ASK FOR
FACTS, FACTS THAT ARE COMING
FORWARD, TO TRY TO CLARIFY WHAT
IS THE STORY, YOU ARE GUILTY OF
CONSPIRACY.
NO NEED TO MAKE AN AFFIRMATIVE
CASE, RIGHT.
TYPICALLY QUESTIONING THE FACTS
MAKES YOU GUILTY OF A
CONSPIRACY.
>> WHAT YOU HAVE SEEN HERE IS
THEY WILL ACTUALLY WEAPONIZE THE
MOST BASIC PRINCIPLES OF
FACT-FINDING AND WHAT IS
SUPPOSEDLY JOURNALISM AGAINST
PEOPLE.
YOU ASKED THE QUESTION.
WE JUST SAW THE HORRIFIC TRAGEDY
OF UVALDE, TEXAS.
POLICE WERE LYING.
THE REPORTS WERE ENTIRELY FALSE,
AND THERE WAS A REASON FOR IT.
PEOPLE TRYING TO COVER-UP FOR
FOR THEIR ENTIRELY INADEQUATE
AND HONESTLY AWFUL RESPONSE.
SO YOU WANT TO SAY WHY CAN'T WE
KNOW THE TRUTH?
IF IT IS SO STRAIGHTFORWARD,
SUCH AN OBVIOUS STORY, WHY ARE
THERE TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THAT HAVE DIFFERENT
FACTS?
THAT'S JUST A REALITY.
THEY CAN SAY IT'S QANON OR
CONSPIRACY OR LUNACY BUT HOW
ABOUT JUST THE TRUTH?
WE ALL KNOW THEY DIDN'T WANT
THAT BEFORE THE ELECTION AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO WANTED ON
THIS ISSUE FOR A LONG TIME.
>> Will: SOMEBODY'S GOING TO
NEED TO GET THE BODY CAM FINISH.
GETTING THEM ON THE SAME PAGE
BECAUSE THERE FACTS ARE GETTING
IN T